- [Matt] Hey, Legal Eagle.
Where does skill end and chance begin
when it comes to gambling?
- Matt, I am so glad you asked
because every state has
different laws on this.
Most states use what's called
the Dominant Factor Test.
It determines whether
something is luck or skill.
Is it about luck,
or predominantly about skill?
And there are four subtests:
is the contest impossible
to win without skill?
Does the average player have enough skill
to participate in the game?
Does skill determine the
actual result of the game,
not simply an aspect of it?
And are participants aware of the skill
and criteria that will be
used to determine the winner?
And I regret to inform you
that states are all over the map on this.
Some states say that games
like Three-card Monte,
video games that award free replays,
and puzzle games are games of skill.
But generally, they agree
that games like Bingo or Dice
are completely about luck
and have no skill involved.
And then when it comes to
games like Pinball and Poker,
well, some states say
they're games of chance
and some say they're games of skill.
So, it depends.
But that's just a theory,
a legal theory!